ich habe mir geht es gut lemberg ist
nach wie vor die sicherste stadt in der
ukraine wir haben zwar jetzt gerade
wieder ein luftalarm aber bislang ist
überhaupt nichts passiert zum glück wir
erleben hier weniger den krieg als die
folgen dieses krieges sind
hunderttausende menschen die hier
ankommen aus dem osten des landes aus
monsheim gerade ist das sind menschen
die schwer traumatisiert sind die zum
teil am ganzen körper zitternd und
weinend wenn sie herankommt die manchmal
eine nacht bleiben und dann aber auch
nicht länger hier in lemberg wir bleiben
möchten sondern sofort zum bahnhof gehen
zum busbahnhof und einfach nur versuchen
heraus zu kommen weil sie immer noch so
unter schock stehen von dem was die
russischen truppen angetan haben und du
hast uns heute abend auch eine these
mitgebracht wo du sagst die muss
diskutiert werden im deutschen fernsehen
ganz genau ich bin ja wie gesagt in
lemberg ich sehe jeden tag was dieser
krieg mit dem menschen macht und mich
hat das in den ersten tagen erstmal sehr
positiv überrascht wie in deutschland
plötzlich viele menschen viele politiker
aufgewacht sind aber einer scheint noch
immer nicht aufgewacht zu sein und das
ist kein spd politiker kein
linkspolitiker keine fdp politiker
sondern dass es sachsens
cdu-ministerpräsident
michael kretschmer der seit jahren ein
sehr enges verhältnis zum kreml hat und
ich habe gehofft dass er jetzt zumindest
endlich versteht wie falsch das war was
für eine fehlannahme das war dass man
mit putin irgendeiner art von
partnerschaft haben kann aber nein er
spricht weiterhin von einer engen
partnerschaft mit russland erfordert im
westen dazu auf in diesem konflikt auch
verbal abzurüsten
erfordert im westen dazu auf dass man
den konflikt nicht weiter anheizt
ich wäre das absolut unbegreiflich wie
ein deutscher politiker auch der
bundesregierung damit ein vorwurf machen
kann während sehr russische truppen sind
die gerade hf in schutt und asche legen
die tiere umzingelt haben die 1000 druck
rheinischer zivilisten getötet haben
wir sind gerade in deutschland dabei die
causa schröder endlich aufzuarbeiten wir
sind dabei uns anzuschauen was manuela
schwesig die ministerpräsidentin der spd
in mecklenburg vorpommern getan hat aber
ich würde auch mittlerweile sagen die
cdu hat in form von michael kretschmer
ein ganz ernsthaftes putin problem das
es zu lösen gilt
julian kaum jemand cover die politik und
vor allem ja auch die konflikte so sehr
wie du siehst du das auch so hat die cdu
an putin problem ich glaube die cdu hat
ein protein problem aber dieses dieses
problem geht weiter und ich finde es
sehr wichtig überhaupt was was philipp
gerade gesagt hat wir gucken beim thema
pro russisch oder pro krimi gucken wir
immer in deutschland auf afd und linke
die ideologisch sehr nah dran sind an
dem kreml die auch unterstützt werden
als wenn ich mir ein als an den bund
letzten bundestagswahlkampf wird mit
werbung usw aber ich glaube philipp
hatten ganz guten punkt und ich würde ja
noch erweitern denn wir haben ein
problem mit kremltreuen politikern in
der mitte unserer gesellschaft und der
kritischen mal ist das krasseste
beispiel jemand der also jetzt einfach
weitermacht und der einfach sagt das ist
mir doch egal wir bleiben einfach so
aber ich möchte auch andere leute noch
einmal andere politiker und nicht in der
cdu sondern in der csu und der spd noch
einmal nennen hier die in den letzten
tagen zurück gerudert sind in den
letzten tagen gesagt haben da ja sagt
das haben wir nicht erwartet was dieser
putin macht und so und ich möchte
herausstellen wie unglaublich
scheinheilig das ist und ich möchte da
einfach mal drei leute nennen wenn es in
ordnung ist zum einen du hast du schon
gesagt manuela schwesig die noch vor
einem jahr für eine umweltstiftung von
der die ganze welt wusste ist keine
umweltstiftung sondern einen ort zudem
zwei stiftungen hier einfach gesagt hat
ich nehme mir 20 millionen euro von
gazprom und macht damit in politik macht
damit innenpolitik macht damit angeblich
umweltpolitik eigentlich ging es nur an
die amerika politik zu machen denn wer
sich genau angeguckt hat worum es
dagegen in dieser stiftung das war
nichts anderes als die sanktionen zu
umgehen der amerikaner dafür wurde das
genommen und da wohnen tatsächlich auch
schiffe mit gecovert diese frau die
jetzt vor ein paar tagen sagt ja dass
das weiß ich gar nicht wie das passieren
konnte diese stiftung mozart aufgelöst
naja was ja gut dann macht es ja ganz
schlimm wo ich mich frage hat ihr das
zum ersten mal in ihrem leben ja wir
haben auch von t-online beispielsweise
gehört die online modi herausgefunden
dass sie sich mal wieder mit herrn
schröder getroffen hat dass sie immer
wieder geheimtreffen hatte mit mit ihrem
alten parteikader und und dort sich
abgesprochen hat wie kann man das machen
wie kann man diese diese pipeline am
besten herr schröder arbeitet für die
pipeline bis vor kurzem die es seit zwei
tagen pleite das finde ich sehr schön 19
2 gibt es nicht mehr die ag
trotzdem die dieses ganz plötzliche
zweites beispiel würde ich nochmal sagen
damit wir auch da ein bisschen weg
kommen aus dieser spd ecke ist herr
söder markus söder hat im letzten und
vorletzten winter kroner pandemie
versucht wahlkampf zu machen und
versucht russland politik zu machen
indem er diesen sputnik fünf impfstoff
der von vornherein als russland benutzt
wurde als als mittel der hybriden
kriegsführung freunde haben hingekriegt
feinde haben ihn nicht gekriegt wer
etwas dagegen gesagt hat warum sofort
werde denen gemachte die wie die
italiener beispielsweise der hat das
ganz großes gekriegt und jeder hat
mitgemacht also diese firma die sputnik
fünf hergestellt hat hat niemals auch
nur annähernd genug unterlagen geliefert
studien geliefert damit dass in der eu
an gebracht werden konnte und er hat
immer gesagt er muss jetzt schnell eine
entscheidung her und wir brauchen das
und hat nach bayern eine fabrik geholt
also eine russische firma eine mit
staaten oder eine ziemlich dadurch
verbundene firma die in bayern das
produzieren sollte hat natürlich auch
gesagt am ersten tag des krieges es wird
kein sprint 5 bei uns produziert ich
habe das gemacht weil wir immer so ist
das hätte man jahre vorher machen können
und jeder hat es gewusst aber er hat
gewartet bis tausende ukrainer sterben
mussten um das zu machen und das dritte
und letzte und dann bin ich auch fertig
und dann können wir auch darüber noch
mal diskutieren ist ja platzeck auch
herr platzeck ehemalige spd chef
matthias platzeck und ministerpräsident
von brandenburg hat vor zwei tagen
gesagt also ich bin nicht mehr chef des
deutsch russischen forums weil was der
herr putin da macht das habe ich nicht
von ihm erwartet und da muss ich sagen
wie naiv kann man sein wie blauäugig
kann man sein herz auch herr platzeck
nimmt wie frau schwesig seit jahren geld
des kreml an die gottschalk auf stiftung
die staatliche stiftung des kreml
kofinanziert seine sitzung in moskau in
berlin in potsdam usw und gibt den
deutsch russischen forum geld damit
diese ganzen politiker dort eingeladen
werden können und diese drei habe ich
jetzt mal genannt und die sind aber nur
stellvertretend für eine politische
elite in deutschland die seit jahren so
tut als wäre das alles nicht so schlimm
ja da war mal die krim jahr da war
syrien da wurde mal 7000 leute zu tode
gekommen alles nicht so wichtig aber
jetzt macht's plötzlich klick und sie
sagen jaja das wussten wir alles nicht
und ich sagte dass dieser satz davon
haben wir nichts gewusst der ist in
deutschland leider sehr berühmt und
berüchtigt und der gilt einfach nicht
mehr
hervor sie haben lange im kanzleramt
beraten erst mal ins mal nach diesem
statement von dir julians sehr geplättet
see ist die deutsche politik so schlimm
sind die deutschen politiker so schlimm
dass man ihn diese vorwürfe machen
sollte
naja das thema russland ist schon ein
schwieriges thema nicht ich war ja auch
bei gesprächen dabei mit putin und die
kanzlerin war ja auch während des der
ganzen ukraine krise auch nach der
annexion der krim war sie so die haupt
vermittlerin ein licht des westens mit
mit putin und wir konnten damals dankbar
sein das ist so jemanden gab weil putin
hätte mit keinem anderen gesprochen weil
er kam nahm auch keinen anderen ernst
und gerade in der phase war es wichtig
dass wir mit angela merkel so ein
sprachrohr hatten nicht das selber auch
erlebt das war auch faszinierend wenn
sie da auf internationalen konferenzen
dann plötzlich auch mit dem russisch
sprach konnte einfach in seiner sprache
reden und eher umgekehrt ja auch deutsch
gleich und das ist natürlich ein problem
aber sie wir müssen halt gucken jetzt
perspektivisch wir haben da fehler
gemacht grobe fehler gemacht spätestens
seit der annexion der krim hätte man
wisse ja zum beispiel bei der annexion
der krim nicht knallhart zu sagen das
ist jetzt die rote linie und jetzt
machen wir das alte system also den
alten kontakt mit putin sohn nicht
weiter wie die geschilderten beispiel
zeigen hat man das ja nicht gemacht wenn
ich mal hat auch nicht die richtigen
schlussfolgerungen gezogen nach der
annexion der können für die sicherheits
und verteidigungspolitik das macht man
jetzt seit ein paar tagen recht
dazwischen ist ja auch viel passiert nun
ist man immer klüger wenn man aus dem
rathaus kommt das stimmt auch aber
das sind schon
aus heutiger sicht fehler denn er hat ja
die ukraine regelrecht überfallen vor
ein paar tagen und das ist ja auch ein
kulturbruch das ist eine richtige zäsur
auch in europa nicht das hat es ja seit
45 nicht mehr gegeben wenn man so will
aber er hat warum hat man diese fehler
gemacht warum hat man da die rote linie
nicht gezogen die kanzlerin war doch so
berühmt dafür dass sie angeblich alles
vom ende her denkt und das ende ihrer
russlandpolitik ist die fast vernichtung
der ukraine können sie uns erklären
warum die bundeskanzlerin diesen
schweren fehler begangen hat und
offenbar putin nicht gebremst hat obwohl
doch alles für alle fakten auf dem tisch
lagen naja ich glaube so einfach ist das
nicht also sie hat auch was nato
mitgliedschaft der ukraine anbelangt da
aufs bremspedal getreten also seit
diesen berühmten nato-gipfel 2008 in
bukarest ich war selber mit dabei und
sie hat damals gesagt leute wir sollten
das nicht überstürzen weil es damals
auch aus ihrer sicht für die ukraine
schwer gewesen wäre weil sie
innenpolitisch damit auch ein problem
hatte es gab damals nicht nur
befürworter
das hat sich heute alles geändert und
nach der annexion der krim mit
sicherheit auch aber das sind natürlich
entwicklungen auf der zeitachse wir
wissen heute mehr man konnte damals
nicht ahnen dass er die ukraine einfach
überfällt brech und
heute ist es allerdings so wo man auch
in die zukunft schauen müssen so krass
das ist was da im moment abläuft die
nato ist nicht willens einen krieg zu
führen die amerikaner sind es auch nicht
dass muss man ganz klar sagen und dieser
versprecher von biden in washington der
war für mich schon sehr sehr eindeutig
wo es darum ging bei meiner in kirchens
durch durch russland schaut man nicht so
genau hin das muss man sich mal das
waren für mich eine freudsche
fehlleistung weil damit wurde eigentlich
signalisiert also die claims zwischen
washington moskau sind abgesteckt und er
kann das eben machen was er jetzt im
moment macht nicht in dieser krassen
form aber man muss einfach sehen wie
kommen wir da raus ohne in einen krieg
und damit in einen weltkrieg zu gehen ja
ich will kommen da nur raus wenn wir
irgendwann wieder mit diesen menschen
reden trotzdem ganzen was gemacht hat
oder er wird weggeputzt von seinen
oligarchen die haben sich ja auch jetzt
gegen ihn ausgesprochen das steht ja
auch massiv unter druck durch dieses
ganze sanktionspaket das ist zwar nicht
kriegsentscheidend aber es ist schwer er
steht auch innenpolitisch unter druck
weil die russische bevölkerung leidet ja
mit der rubel der stürzt ins ins abseits
china selbst hat gesagt also das ist
nicht unser verbündeter was er da macht
damit wollen wir nichts zu tun haben und
hat heute nicht mit ihnen gebetet vom
genau investition genau und das ist eine
schwierige situation und jetzt müssen
wir gucken wie gehen wir damit weiter um
ja wir können wir können sagen ja okay
wir machen ihnen das leben zur hölle er
kann nicht so leicht reingehen die ich
in der sendung lassen wir philipp einmal
darauf jetzt reagieren dass er auch
seine reaktion auf die erklärung
natürlich von ihnen herr fahrt geben
darf
die frage nämlich umtreibt die hat der
vater angesprochen ist
wäre die nato denn bereit ein
nato-mitglied zu verteidigen wir sehen
jetzt wie die vokale zwar hier und da
mit waffen unterstützt wird aber wie ich
finde noch bei weitem nicht genug was
wenn putin als nächstes sich estland
holen will wer dann die nato sagen oh ja
es ist ein nato-mitglied oder polen oder
was auch immer und dann eingreifen oder
wird die nahezu sagen ach das ist ja nur
so ein kleines land wollen wir wirklich
den großen krieg mit russland da würd
mich sehr interessieren was die runde
dazu sagt frau möchten sie antworten auf
der piazza ich glaube wir haben das
problem damit wir überhaupt einen
konfliktfreien wir sprechen über die
nato über den konflikt zwischen nato und
russland
aber eigentlich das was wir heute
erleben das ist ein konflikt zwischen
dem westlichen system das heißt zwischen
dem demokratischen system und einem
autoritären system und eigentlich weder
kampf um die ukraine sozusagen ausgehen
wird wird auch unsere zukunft darunter
davon abhängen heute ich glaube die nato
und auch mitglieder der europäischen
union
nato-staaten sag ich so müssen sich
überlegen wie können sie vielleicht
durch unkonventionelle wege oder so sich
überlegen wie können sie die ukraine
unterstützen sei es zum beispiel
naja wenn wir ihr war auch diese
flugverbotszone sprechen wir wissen auch
haben wir uns auch mit militärischen
experten darüber unterhalten dass
vielleicht dass es nicht möglich ist wie
die ganze ukraine die flugverbotszone
einzuführen aber gleichzeitig müssen wir
uns gedanken machen was würde passieren
wenn zum beispiel eine rakete ein
atomkraftwerk in der ukraine
treffen wird und die atomare meinen
grenzen die die automaten gefahren haben
keinen grenzen und ich glaube aber sehr
schwierig ist auch in deutschland wir
haben das gefühl manchmal ja die
sanktionen sind eingeführt und so wir
haben unser was geleistet aber wir
schauen nicht weiter der konflikt würden
nicht aufhören was wir schon in der
ukraine erleben dass die zivilisten
erschossen werden und ich glaube dass
sofern wir nicht moderieren und ich
frage mich auch wo ist die schmerzgrenze
wie viele menschen sollen in der ukraine
leben damit wir dann sagen wir können
dann eingreifen was der ukrainische
präsident jetzt vor kurzem gemacht hat
er hat eine internationale legion jetzt
gegründet das heißt ausländer aus
anderen staaten dürfen jetzt der
ukrainischen armee anschließen
und ich glaube durch solche nicht
konservativer wege versucht man auch
andere seiten an eigene seite zu ziehen
und damit die ukraine diesen trick nicht
verliert vor allem das merkt man ja auch
hier in der runde die stammzuschauer von
48 werden es bemerkt haben das war
glaube ich das erste mal dass hier zwei
thesen in einer zusammenhang weil
philipp und du etwas so ein ähnliches
thema für heute ausgesucht habt julian
wo wir jetzt mal zwei thesen schon auf
einmal hatten und ich finde das zeigt so
sehr wie enttäuscht man auch selbst als
deutsche von politikern ist ich zum
beispiel sehr von gerd schröder muss ich
einfach sagen mich enttäuscht doch sehr
dass er 407 407
hunderttausend euro im jahr erhält vom
deutschen staat und dann ja eigentlich
ja gestern hat mein kollege der politik
chef jan schäfer gesagt er sollte nach
moskau fliegen ich sehe dass
mittlerweile auch wirklich ehrlich so
jeden fall kein geld mehr vom deutschen
staat einstreichen aber was auch fakt
ist und da würde ich gerne
wir fragen wie sich der deutsche staat
verhalten soll wenn man auf die energien
blickt paul also energietechnische sind
wir nun von diesen despoten abhängig was
sollen wir denn eigentlich machen jetzt
als deutscher staat
ja vielleicht ganz aktuelle nachrichten
die sich gerade bestätigt haben frau
monique hat es ja angesprochen wie sehr
russland auf die zivile bevölkerung hier
zielt und wir hören dass die
diskussionen die wir ungefähr vor 30
minuten gehört haben offenbar in
richtung eines wasser
heizwerks gerichtet waren das müssen wir
gleich noch mal weiter recherchieren
aber das sind jetzt die ukrainische
meldungen das bedeutet dass
möglicherweise teile der stadt das in
teilen weiteren teilen der stadt das
warme wasser ausfallen wird unabhängig
davon ob es dann möglicherweise auch
opfer gegeben hat diese meldungen sind
noch nicht ganz klar aber man sieht auch
in dem minuten wo wir hier diskutieren
findet putins krieg weiterstadt was die
energieabhängigkeit angeht muss man
einmal ganz klar sagen dass wir das so
viele jahre mitgemacht haben war einfach
wahnsinnig naiv und hat unserem land
geschadet dass man sich so abhängig
gemacht hat weil es wäre ja nicht nötig
gewesen und ich bin kein anhänger der
atomenergie persönlich geprägt durch
debatten
der vergangenen jahrzehnte aber dennoch
ist es sicherlich etwas worüber man in
deutschland wieder nachdenken muss
geradezu dazu zählen aber auch andere
energiequellen wir können nicht sagen
wir wollen kein russisches gas mehr und
dann unsere bevölkerung sagen gut dann
müsste die nächsten jahre bis der
präsident putin weg ist frieren das geht
ja nicht von daher müssen wir uns da
gedanken machen und vor allem so bitter
das ist energie wird am ende eher teurer
werden wahrscheinlich viel teurer werden
und da muss es dann auch in einer ampel
koalition
denke ich die möglichkeit geben
denjenigen zu helfen die nicht so viel
geld im geldbeutel haben um sich diese
energie zu leisten weil was würden
ertragen können sind bilder von vielen
frierenden menschen weil die heizungen
ausgefallen ist aber paul also du sagst
du bist kein großer befürworter von
kernenergie und natürlich die aktuelle
kernenergiepolitik wurde von der großen
koalition beschlossen dass durch mir
nicht vergessen aber ich habe mich doch
sehr gewundert als ich gestern unseren
energieminister jahren habe ich gehört
habe der gesagt hat ja also so wird es
jetzt auch nicht dazu ich bin durch
genau wie super das wollte er ist jetzt
aussieht müssen wir vielleicht die kohle
länger laufen lassen will ich sage jetzt
kohle jetzt ganz im ernst also wir haben
doch gerade 30 er kraftwerke die nicht
von heute auf morgen wieder hochgefahren
werden können die verbraucher ausgemacht
haben diese energie brauchen wir und
auch diese dieses argument immer zu
sagen ja das wird aber teurer dann und
so ich habe jetzt gerade mein
gasanbieter hat nach einem jahr mir
natürlich gerade gekündigt und hat ihr
neues angebot gemacht
340 prozent 340 prozent preissteigerung
von 5,5 cent auf 15 19 pro
kilowattstunde und das ist die realität
nicht von mir sondern von allen wir
sehen das seit und das ist immer dass
das foto sei trotz stream 2 fertig ist
seit august letzten jahres meldet sich
bei uns check24 und andere
vergleichsportale und sagen es ist
verrückt ja jetzt wohl das fertig ist
dann schalten die russen nacheinander
zuerst so kann ein netzwerk aus nichts
mehr extra gebucht dann die ja mal
halblang seit dezember ausgeschaltet wir
haben nur noch 19 1 unsere einzige
energiequelle wir sind völlig abhängig
davon und auch da muss ich sagen frau
merkel hat noch im dezember gesagt wir
sind nicht abhängig von russischem gas
das ist wahnsinnig wenn ich das höre
kurz danach war das argument ja wir sind
total abhängig vom russischen gas und
deshalb können wir jetzt keine weiteren
sanktionen beschließen
also da muss ich mich erst wonach muss
auch sagen die die kernenergie liebe
daher und die uns zur verfügung steht
und die in vielen vielen anderen
europäischen ländern sicher angewandt
wird dass wir die nicht wieder ausbauen
dass wir die nicht wieder zurück fahren
und diese diese fehlentscheidung von
2011 rückgängig machen das ist mir nicht
klar denn ich sehe jetzt nochmal eine
verdreifachung seiner gasrechnung und
ich habe keine lust zu frieren ganz
ehrlich und deshalb bin ich auch für
andere energie erfahren sie gedacht dass
im deutschen fernsehen mal so ein
plädoyer für die kernenergie noch hören
oder eher selten zeit alle linien
gefallen denkverbote sind weg der
diskurs ist wieder offen nein also ich
hätte ich hätte das nicht gedacht das
ist schon sehr krass ich muss aber sagen
natürlich hat das eine hat dass ein
rationaler das ist schon ganz klar und
das zeigt aber auch wie schwierig ist
jetzt die regierung hat die müssen ja
mit einer ganzen menge von maximen
prinzipien brechen einfach und das ist
ja ein punkt recht die die kernkraft
wurde ja regelrecht verteufelt in
deutschland manche ausländische
beobachter sagen ja das ist diese
irrationale seite der deutschen von
heute die sind gegen kernkraft und zwar
ganz massiv kein anderes land der welt
nur massiv ja ja und jetzt müssen wir
neu darüber nachdenken das geht ja auch
in die anderen felder rhein in der
sicherheitspolitik waffenexporte in ein
kriegsgebiet zack es läuft nicht dann
die nukleare teilhabe jetzt durch die
atomare bedrohung ja auch von von putin
das ist weg vom fenster wahrscheinlich
werden wir 35 kaufen und werden die news
in deutschland lagern und wir
transportieren sie dann im bedarfsfall
dahin wo sie wo sie hingehören oder
drohen damit an das wäre unvorstellbar
noch vor einer woche da hätte jeder
politiker also gerade der grünen gesagt
das findet nicht statt 100 milliarden
für die bundeswehr
unvorstellbar also dass man sieht da
hatten der ganze koalitionsvertrag in
ganz wichtigen aussagen der ist
makulatur
regeln dieser aggression fahren weil es
mich und lass mich interessieren
weiß was mich interessieren würde was
ihre meinung dazu ist wie die kanzlerin
wenn sie noch im amt wäre also nehmen
wir an sie hätte noch eine fünfte
amtszeit angestrebt und wäre jetzt noch
kanzlerin und wäre in dieser krise
erstens wie würde sie sich gegenüber der
ukraine verhalten und zweitens glauben
sie dass die kanzlerin bereit wäre zu
sagen die lage ist jetzt anders ich habe
fehler gemacht deswegen machen wir jetzt
wieder atomenergie
ja das ist eine echt gute frage ich weiß
es nicht ich weiß es nicht ich kann es
nicht beantworten was sie machen würde
aber es ist sicherlich auch teil dieser
strategie von putin gewesen zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt das zu machen ich denke der
weiß da ist eine neue deutsche regierung
aus drei parteien die sind müssen sich
erst warm machen die haben viele
probleme intern wird auch mit ihren
themen usw und da gibt es den
französischen präsidenten der ist hat
zwar die eu ratspräsidentschaft
er wird im april gewählt keiner weiß ob
er bleibt nicht dann gibt es einen
schwachen amerikanischen präsidenten und
im hintergrund ein donald trump der
vielleicht in drei jahren wieder kommt
und all das spielt sie sicherlich auch
mit und hat hat seinen entschluss
begünstigt wenn überhaupt es jetzt
durchzuziehen was er jetzt gerade macht
das muss man auch sehen also diese frage
was würde merkel machen kann in der
situation kann ich wirklich nicht mehr
beantworten sie ist nicht mehr im amt
rangnick aber dazu muss ich sagen dass
wenn wir jetzt über die reaktion des
westens sprechen dann war das schon sehr
einheitlich und der westen hat sich von
sehr guten seite eigentlich gezeigt das
einzige und ich glaube der russische
präsident hat schon damit gerechnet dass
nämlich der westen jetzt die schwäche
zeigen wird was mich ich glaube noch mal
würde ich nochmal zurück auf den punkt
warum die ja so naiv waren ich glaube
was wir immer unterschätzt haben die
öffentliche meinung in deutschland und
journalisten auch über die annexion
betrieben berichtet haben wir hatten
damals schon so erleben so eine krise
der begriffe wir wussten auch nicht wie
sollen wir die russischen soldaten
bezeichnen wir hatten immer so grüne
männchen bezeichnet wird das hat alles
einen einfluss auf die öffentliche
meinung und auch dies und das prägt den
discos und dementsprechend der diskurs
hat auch einen einfluss auf die politik
der unterschied den wir jetzt erleben in
diesem krieg wir wissen ganz genau mit
welchen begriffen wir dieses vorgehen
von russland bezeichnen sollen und ich
glaube für die zukunft das ist
unglaublich wichtig zu verstehen welche
begriffe wir nutzen um ein verbrechen zu
bezeichnen davor ich glaube hat schon
der russische präsident auch angst und
ich bin sehr froh dass wir jetzt eine
ganz klare begriffe haben um dann den
den den überfall dass sein russland auch
die ukraine mit zu bezeichnen ein
weiteres beispiel dafür vielleicht unter
sich bis heute es wird immer noch von
prorussischen separatisten
durchgesprochen das ist dieses fantasie
bord was man sich mannomann ausgedacht
hat und was aber machen die
öffentlich-rechtlichen bis heute
durchgehalten wird bis heute in den akt
wenn berichten russischer soldaten an
der seite von pro russischen
separatisten usw die so genannten pro
sichere separatisten man weiß seit
jahren dass sie aus moskau finanziert
aus moskau bewaffnet und mittlerweile
die anführer russische staatsbürger sind
und mitglieder der putin partei einiges
russland sind also mehr russisch geht
gar nicht und trotzdem hat man dieses
sind sperrigen begriff das ist was ganz
differenziertes und da muss man genau
hingucken und das sollte man nicht im
putin an lassen bis heute und wohl noch
das problem sehe
dass wir immer denken dass die russisch
gelenkten medien journalisten sind das
sind nicht mehr journalisten und wir
versuchen durch verschiedene talkshows
immer so verschiedene meinungen
darzustellen das ist keine pluralität
wir haben menschen die heute als
instrumenten des krieges genutzt werden
und diejenigen die jetzt den krieg in
der ukraine verfolgen wissen ganz genau
wie videos da dargestellt werden wie
lügen über lügen verbreitet werden und
da ich glaube das ist auch eine
herausforderung für journalisten
und auch für die rolle der journalistin
und ich frage mich wie wird das
weitergehen und wie vielleicht sollten
wir auch die rolle der journalisten
heute neu definieren